Jennifer walters is an attorney who has
accidentally taken in the hulk's blood
and has become like a chick
hole a she-hulk exactly
that's got a nice ring to it
that name better not stick
there's something so surreal and so funny about
a giant six foot seven hulk in the courtroom
it was about putting a real human
being into these absurd situations
it's just like as cool and
edgy as we can get away with
girl your ass looks crazy right now
it's something that you think you knew
which is law shows and something that
you think you know which is marvel shows
smash together this show is so much fun it all
has this tongue-in-cheek self-referential thing
going on in the comics she broke the fourth wall
and was super meta i just want to make sure that
you don't think this is one of those cameo every
week type of shows well except bruce and polonsky
she spent all this time becoming a
lawyer and this idea of being a superhero
is not appealing to her being a superhero
is a trial by fire oh i'm not a superhero
i just want to be a normal anonymous lawyer
there is no going back to what you were before
who's going to protect the
world if not people like you
this is expanding the definition of
what a marvel studios production can be
this is a radical revolutionary show can
we get some shots please it's an emergency
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
she-hulk trailer video there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs and a bunch of you are asking
about what's going on with ghost rider during
the trailer don't worry i'll explain what's up
with that because it's a bit of an in-universe
joke that they're having because of all the
different trials that they're having in each
of the episodes which is where all the cameos
are coming from i will be doing videos for all
the episodes be sure to subscribe to get them
all they're going to be starting really soon
but just starting with the big stuff here first
they reveal what her new origin story is going
to be inside the mcu so you see her crash
there with a version of bruce banner his arm
is in the sling so like his arm is still hurt
like it was after the shanxi post credit scene
still damaged from using the infinity gauntlet
during avengers end game he's also still in banner
form but it seems like what happens is they get
into a car accident somehow their car goes off the
road and then his gamma-infused blood mixes with
her blood accidentally contaminating her giving
her the powers of the hook like the gamma-infused
blood slowly takes over her normal blood
in the original version in the comics it was
actually a trial that she was in the middle of
she was busy prosecuting the mob they put out
a hit on her and unsuccessfully tried to kill
her she was sent to the hospital and the only
person who had compatible blood who was nearby
was bruce banner her cousin but also because he
had the gamma-infused blood when he gave her the
transfusion to save her life that gave her the
powers of the hulk while she was recuperating the
hospital the mob tried to come finish the job
and kill her again and that's when her powers
activated and she transformed into the she-hulk
for the first time it sounds like there's going
to be a twist on that in the series where she
gets into an accident with him gets infused with
his gamma blood and then something happens to her
later where she just transforms without realizing
what's happened and then she goes to him to learn
to how to handle her powers so this just confirms
where it takes place in the timeline after the
events of the shangshi movie now that we know
that all the scenes of them training with his arm
being healed happen after this accident his arm
isn't in the sling anymore a lot of you asking how
did that happen how did his arm heal why didn't it
do that before that probably has something to do
with their accident and his training with her like
through the course of the first couple episodes
they'll explain how his arm heals if you're not
a longtime hook comic book reader too the whole
idea of his gamma powers is that they're nearly
limitless like there are more powerful versions of
the hulk like there's the version of the hulk that
becomes the herald of galactus and gets the power
of cosmic world breaker hulk is more powerful than
any of the versions we've seen in the mcu so
far it is all just a function of his rage like
how angry can you possibly get and theoretically
the idea is that it's limitless and the idea the
more powerful they get the more their rage scales
the quicker they heal damage like this so like the
professor hulk version is a less powerful version
of the hulk than the incredible hulk version like
full hulk version he could naturally increase his
power and eventually heal damage on this level
like during the immortal hulk there's a version
of him fighting a version of the one below which
is sort of like the opposite of the one above
all the one true god of the marvel universe
making him kind of like the one true devil or one
true villain of the marvel universe more like a
cosmic entity on a higher order than characters
like mephisto and the other hell lords like the
different characters that you would associate
in marvel comics with the christian ideal of
the devil they have the big training montage it
sounds like that's going to be a big part of the
early episodes when they're on his special island
and he does that special attack where he slaps his
hands together that's actually from the incredible
hulk there are multiple references to the edward
norton incredible hulk during the series most of
them coming through the abominations character in
all of his scenes because he's literally the same
version of the abomination from the incredible
hulk movie with the edward norton hulk and the
only reason why they changed his appearance
in present day i talked about this during my
shanxi videos because of the big abomination
and wong scene is they've just teased that
his gamma transformation over time has evolved
and now he looks more accurate to the comic book
version of abomination comic book abomination
always looked like this the reason why they didn't
make him look like this during incredible hulk is
just because when they were releasing that it
was so early in marvel phase one they were so
gun shy about doing weird stuff they wanted his
face to look more human now they're totally not
afraid of doing weird stuff so of course they're
just gonna do a more comic book accurate version
also at the beginning here when she does that
scream pose where she's yelling at the hulk after
she attacks him that's meant to be a reference
to the savage she-hulk in the comic book covers
they have more of her fourth wall breaking scenes
like there's a big one in the trailer where she
directly references all the week-to-week cameo
scenes then showing you the jokey deadpool type
tone of her fourth wall breaks she takes back
her own joke like oh wait a minute except for
the bruce banner hulk cameo scene abomination all
the wong all the daredevil obviously that's just
the beginning those aren't the only cameos during
the series for those of you also asking about the
fourth wall breaking she's not copying deadpool
because she hulk actually broke the fourth ball
many many years before deadpool was ever known for
breaking the fourth wall so technically deadpool
would be copying her but the other big reveal is
that the emil blonsky abomination is currently
working it seems like or has been working as a
self-help guru holding seminars that it seems
like are targeted in most of the super villain
and superhero community because you see titania
at one of them we'll see if this is mostly a front
and he's just pretending to be good like he's been
working with wong so it seems like he's been
trying to learn to control his transformations
but i think we all expect him to be recruited by
val into the thunderbolts but the thunderbolts
movie isn't coming to like the end of marvel phase
five so it's going to be obama before we actually
see that team come together but i think we're
all expecting to see like a scene at the end of
the series where she shows up and is like hey i'm
putting together a team if you look on the left
side in the background here too the oppo maste
poster is probably a reference to the abomination
name and what he just calls his technique for
self-help and meditation that he's developed the
other big easter egg that people are talking about
here there are like a lot more wong scenes inside
this magic club inside this theater looking room
where you see what looks like a ghost rider easter
egg because just based on reports about the series
wong is actually suing this magician character you
see in court for being a charlatan like wong is
actually suing him and that's why wang is in the
series but when you see the poster up in front of
his stage like where he gives his performances you
see that it says donnie blaze which is meant to be
a clever wink at johnny blaze and they did a lot
of work during doctor strange too to sort of set
up the supernatural lore inside the mcu in a much
deeper way the idea of how these other dimensions
like the hell dimension mephisto's dimension
ghost rider is a character can actually exist
because they talk about the darkhold they talk
about the souls of the damned you see them doctor
strange uses them to create a cloak of levitation
you hear the souls of the damn start coming for
him saying that he's going to be cursed because
of what he's doing working with this type
of magic is forbidden and it carries a cost
most of the consequences of that they'll probably
deal with in doctor strange three they'll tease in
some of the other supernatural projects marvel
studios just did trademark the midnight sun's
name so it sounds like they plan on doing an
actual midnight sums project at some point but
it might be like marvel phase seven before they
have time to do that because we already know
what all the projects during marvel phase five
the next couple of years in marvel phase six
after that even though there's some mystery
dates here we know what most of those are
they don't really have room for a midnight suns
movie or disney plus series the only real way to
fit them in during marvel phase six would be to
like do them in a version of doctor strange three
because i think that's part of the idea leading up
to the version of avengers 5 kang war and avengers
6 secret wars they'll probably want to pay that
off in doctor strange 3 before avengers 5 happens
they also had that hell universe that they
passed through when they were going through
the different universes and it looks like it was
just meant to be a universe where mephisto or one
of the other hell lords had taken over the entire
universe and transformed it into a version of hell
for those of you all reaching for more mevisto
references sounds like they're slowly heading
in that direction because you can't really do a
version of ghostwriter's origin story unless you
just radically change his backstory with mephisto
but this doesn't mean that actual ghostwriter is
going to cameo during the she-hulk series it just
means it's a clever reference to the ghost rider
character recently ryan gosling also said of all
characters he actually wanted to be a version of
ghost rider so they're like three or four
different huge actors that everybody really
wants to play a version of ghost rider and emcu
any one of them would do a great job during comic
con tatiana maslany also talked about a really
cool daredevil scene she had i think it's supposed
to be a couple episodes like it's not just like
one small moment during a single episode it's a
little bit more than that the way she teased it
there'll be a cameo scene where they're both in
the courtroom acting as lawyers like it's matt
murdock with sheet hulk and then later another
separate scene with them is daredevil and she
holds together the episodes are starting really
soon so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that there's going to be a lot
of big stuff dropping really soon and i got a
couple other trailer videos that i'm working on
my next big one will be for the guardians of the
galaxy comic con trailer in adam warlock while
you wait for everything everyone click here for my
full black panther wakanda forever trailer video
and easter eggs and click here for my brand new
ant-man 3 trailer in avengers 5 kang dynasty video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys in the next one!